a great afternoon drink is a comparti
spritz it's my one of my favorite drinks
I don't even know what that is the party
Spritz compari is an interesting alcohol
because I think it's a bitter uh or it's
a liqueur and it's got a weird rooty
earthy taste it's red so it looks like
Kool-Aid that's why I got into it I
thought camparion ice would be oh so
nice there's an old commercial but man
it's [__] like sucking the green
Giant's dick it is earthy what's earthy
it's like it tastes like Roots it's oh
nice it's not it's not it's oh there's a
bitterness and like a or it's just not
great
and then someone introduced me to a
Negroni which is Campari and gin and a
little soda water and then the Campari
Spritz compari Spritz is Campari
Prosecco and soda water in like a wine
glass and it is
so enjoyable it's got so many different
profiles to it where you get the
bitterness but the sweetness of the
Prosecco and then it flattens it out
with the soda water and it looks like
Kool-Aid so I love it that's one of my
favorite drinks to share in what context
oh uh you're in Italy
and you've been walking around Venice
and everyone went their own ways and the
whole family comes back together and you
meet at a statue and and your wife's
sweating and she's uncomfortable and
your daughters are 16 and 18 and they're
like are what are we gonna what are we
doing with the rest of the day and you
go hey guys it's Europe does anyone want
to come party Spritz and everyone goes I
don't know what that is and you go
[__] party spreads now it's minor in
alcohol so it's not going to light them
up but it gives them a little bit of a
buzz where they're like Dad These are
nice Island didn't drink her so I drank
hers I Georgia had hers Leanne had hers
and we ordered another round I ordered
an and they're
[__] refreshing and the buzz is
perfect it's not too much because it's
just a little bit of champagne and some
Campari if the buzz is perfect and then
a couple of them and then they kind of
disappear and then you're just walking
around again that's a great [__]
drink